- [Voiceover] What is the
sum of all the solutions
to the above equation?
All right, this is interesting.
We have three plus the
square root of six M
six M minus 26 is equal to M.
So any time you have a
radical equation like this,
it's a good idea to try
to isolate the radical.
So, or unless you try to
isolate the radical first.
So let's try to subtract
three from both sides
to just be left with just the radical
on the lefthand side.
And so three minus three is zero
and on the lefthand side
you're just left with the square root
of six M minus 26
and that's going to be
equal to M minus three.
Now, to get rid of the radical,
we can square both sides of this equation.
So, we'll square that side
and then we can square that side as well.
And so the square root of
six M minus 26 squared.
That's going to be six M minus 26,
and then M minus three squared.
That's going to be M squared
minus six M,
it's gonna be minus
three M, minus three M,
plus nine.
And if this step,
you found a little confusing,
I encourage you on Khan Academy to review
multiplying expressions,
so I'll do a quick primer right here.
M minus three times M minus three.
That's the same thing as
M minus three squared.
You'll have M times M,
which is M squared,
M times negative three,
which is negative three M,
negative three times M,
which is negative three M
and then negative three
times negative three
which is positive nine
and the negative three M
plus the negative three M,
that is negative six M.
And I encourage you,
especially 'cause on the SAT,
we'd have to do this under time pressure,
to be able to do things
like square a binomial
like this very quickly
to realize it was gonna be M squared
plus two time the product of these.
The product of these is negative three M,
two times that is negative six M,
then negative three times
negative three is positive nine.
So now let's see if we can solve for M.
So let's get all of...
Let's get all of our everything
on the righthand side
of the equation.
So let's subtract six M from both sides.
So I'm gonna subtract
six M from both sides,
and let's add 26 to both sides.
And the whole reason why I did that
is to just clean out what I
have on the lefthand side.
So on the lefthand side,
I'm just gonna be left with zero,
and on the righthand side
I'm gonna have M squared
minus 12M
plus 35
or I could write M
squared minus 12M plus 35
is equal to zero.
And, so let's think about
the M's that satisfy this.
Well, I can factor this if I think about,
"Well, what two numbers
have a product of 35,
"but if I were to sum them,
I'd get to negative 12?"
Well 35, I can think of seven times five,
but seven plus five is positive 12,
but what about negative
seven times negative five?
Well, their product's gonna be positive 35
and negative seven plus
negative five is negative 12.
So I could factor this into
M minus five
times M minus seven is equal to zero
and if this step does
not make sense to you,
where I factored this quadratic,
I encourage you to look
up factoring quadratics
on Khan Academy to get a little bit more
practice doing that.
But if I have the product of
two things that equal zero,
that means that one or both of them
need to be equal to zero.
So, M minus five
could be zero
or M minus seven would be equal to zero.
Well to make M minus five equal to zero,
you just add five to both sides.
You'd have M is equal to five
or same thing over here,
add seven to both sides,
M is equal to seven.
So the two solutions are five and seven.
If you want the sum
of all the solutions,
it's going to be five plus seven
is equal to 12,
and if you just want to verify
that these actually work,
try them out right over here.
Six times five is going to be
30 minus 26
which is four.
The principle root of
four is positive two.
Three plus two is equal to five.
It's equal to M.
And if M was seven,
if M was seven,
this is gonna be three
plus the square root of
42 minus 26 is 16
and this needs to be equal to seven.
Well, the principle root of 16 is four
and three plus four is indeed
equal to seven.